damn look at you fellas coming in hot
mexican over there i'm a heavy hitter
like javonte davis come on now
damn dog you called it you said he was
going to tear him up knockout of the
year knockout of the year how you enjoy
it oh thank you for that uh show time
for the promo code appreciate it he's a
plug and he got me this t-shirt i do i
am an employee of showtime
exactly so thank you for that also they
sent me a box
and i had a promo code and i said i
wanted to do well on pay-per-view so i
paid my
hard-earned cash for it and then gave
you the promo code yes sir and i watched
it for free
but hold on let me ask you something
when you watch fights and we was at your
house by the way we'll get to that later
um you you guys are the worst to watch
everyone sat on their phones the entire
time
i was watching the phone i was watching
the fight but wait the guy kept asking
you questions i was like yo
i tried mcathy yeah yeah okay do you get
annoyed with me
watch oh oh you you don't get annoyed
when people i can't that's why i watch
fights by myself that's what i did yeah
i didn't want you guys there
wait wait don't you have time you
invited us
not for to the kids birthday party and
then everyone migrated into the
fight area one you that was whatever but
usually no i
i like watching fights just with like my
girl and that's it
because somebody there's so many goddamn
questions so many questions like i had
to recap the fight tomorrow i had to
watch it last night again because
i was talking the entire time like
someone asked me what happened like i
don't [ __ ] i was talking with this
there was a lot going on i did a podcast
with this [ __ ] dude
you were like hello i just want to chill
also your costume got caught on fire
yeah yeah costume caught on fire
missed out on that yeah my father-in-law
uh we've had some whiskey whiskey was
flowing
he just sat down and my girl has a bunch
of [ __ ] candles like we're satanists
and he takes my costume and he's like
i'll just put it here and then
we're all chilling justin's like damn
something's on fire i turn around
oh costume by the way you still got it
with the fast euro step you was uh he
got it he shot him got it you shot a
euro that's all it is
i [ __ ] my shin up so bad i hit it on
that on the chair oh i got a straight
cut it's this big one oh try
trying to get to your fire man oh for
real dude fire
insurance ain't nothing nice that's the
first thing that went through my mind
because if it's started by like a candle
in your house insurance really isn't
that cool to you
they're like oh you've been on the hill
i've been on the hook yeah when it what
was the fire alarm i like yo
yeah yeah well by the way let's just put
the audience in let's just start popping
though let me just talk let me just tell
them
whoever said money doesn't buy happiness
haven't been a british shop house let me
just tell you something
i was so sad but when i pulled up to
this goddamn castle
i was like yo brandon i kept telling
myself please don't steal please don't
stay
i wanted to take the charger he has a
hole yeah we had cameras on you though
i saw that i saw all right do you think
i tell these dick jokes to push a rav
forward west
come on now you know how hard i work for
that [ __ ] house
oh he has a castle dawg i went i wrote
three
stop wearing those [ __ ] shoes dude
you got holes in the back your socks
when you walked in i said did you steal
those from bruce
lee's grave
no he got the debo fit what he got a
prison issue
i've seen those on [ __ ] scarecrow my
shoes are coming they're just not here
yet
oh yeah you got some you just get any
shoe that would be like going from
with the shoe that you got it'd be like
going if it if cars you'd be like
having a 89 honda hey these are not a 89
honda
those are way worse is that give them no
no no you got it better than a no
no no if it's it's like going from an 89
honda
to a goddamn dodge viper like you went
you just
skipped everything and jumped to the
front line
union jordan guava what are they called
unions
union guava eugene jordans they're fours
fours they're they're drunk
do you see them yes sir yeah those are
the shoes i got now i've had them for a
hot second so it's gonna be weird if we
wear them
we can wear this why not you and i wear
shoes the same way all the time yeah
come on man those are your first real
pair of shoes huh it's only
what do you mean real pair of shoes
these are my first real shoes
but stop stop stop stop you're right
i know i can't even in front of these
fans i've had these for a minute
did you bake them this [ __ ]
oh cause the black is gone just just
like they're all like
sunburned and [ __ ] he goes you make
decent money yeah
yeah man you do he is paying as well but
i don't understand
all right i mean okay listen does your
girl say anything and she's she's not
into fashion uh she don't know when i
wear these
because you they're just like your house
slippers what these are yeah house
slippers yeah
these are not house slippers bro i got
house slippers but these are not house
so how does she know you just walk out
the door in some vans like that
oh yeah yeah i mean she don't we don't
live together so oh that's right
otherwise she would say something yeah
my girl like what the [ __ ] yeah
yeah because she does say something like
when i came here last friday that bonus
episode in sweats my girl was like are
you sick i'm like
no i'm just
bro stood up in those sweats though
did you see
what happened yeah legs like me yeah
he's just like he was just all goofy and
sweaty
oh thanks for that gear too you're
looking for a big boy gear
everyone's like damn doesn't make a wish
that was nice you [ __ ]
came over demanding food i had to order
the special panda express for him
he wasn't okay okay you want to eat the
kids pizza before they ate it
so i ordered him food and then he's like
hey any gear i'm like god
damn man you could do a living i know i
was like hey brendan where's the where's
the orange chicken at dude
you did yeah
but you can't invite black people over
and not expect like i didn't eat all day
i was like my girl's like no yeah i
saved my i saved my appetite yeah for
your party that's how we are it's not a
holiday
it's a [ __ ] four-year-old's birthday
or halloween party but food is going to
be there
yeah and there was food there exactly so
don't get mad at us because we was like
hold on i saved
up for brendan i don't know if yeah did
we see those boxes of people bro it was
no no to the audience it was stacks it
wasn't like yo
three or four boxes he had stacks of
pizza for like six or seven we have to
feed the kids first
then you guys could get it oh they ain't
seen so why did you get the orange
chicken yeah they didn't explain that
yeah because you wouldn't shut up
that is true that is panicked i was like
oh [ __ ]
guess i gotta get him a special
family-sized panda
okay like you didn't eat any i had one
plate
bro i had one plate i had one plate
right he always tried to front and then
and then we watched the fights and i
looked over everyone's watching the
fight on their phone like this
no i was watching the fights how was the
tennis look at that
oh that one [ __ ] that doesn't miss does
it no it's consistent
yeah what the what the i can't i can't
remember a time where i've gone there
in order to orange chicken sometimes
sometimes it'd be a little mushy though
if it's
if it's out too long it gets a little
mushy oh i don't wait that long
ooh that [ __ ] is so good fire hit it
right you like it
i love it fire that's why i can't go
anymore because i just i can't stop
oh really i try to make it better by
eating just vegetables and orange
chicken ah but this doesn't work
yeah i know right now it's candy chicken
that's what it is
basically it's the devil that's what it
is
oh it's so fantastic so you feel sick
afterwards
nope i felt good it was a little heavy
everyone got a little tired i got to
sleep oh my god
i got super sleepy yeah did you did you
have some cats no i didn't have some i
had a pizza and then i dip
do you like orange chicken i love orange
chicken do you know anyone who doesn't
like it
i don't i don't trust you if you don't
like orange juice dog you remember at
the
at the mall when they would give out the
samples oh come on now
i should make laps yeah make a laugh
dude
this is how i used to be i have taken uh
the sample i'm like yo this is so good
and i'm like yo i have somebody uh come
with me i'm like hey bro show her what
you just showed me
and then they'll come back with it and
like let me have someone too let me see
more get more i get full off of samples
there you go god damn it
that was the best thing about malls
costco too costco samples
oh yeah costco was cool yeah but then
chick-fil-a's do the same thing once you
just have one little nugget
mm-hmm they give you sounds for the
nugget no i'm just saying like the ball
oh that they just cut a little
slice that fillet off wow that's crazy
that's from jay jay shobby i'm gonna
take friday but you're 100 right
mcdonald's nuggets curb stomp
curb stomp curve that's an american
history actually i know right
and don't even get started on how much
better mcdonald's fries are thanks
for this thanks bro i definitely have to
bring this up on the show
jake goes ll do it it's actually
offensive they think chick plays better
mcdonald's what the f and then jay goes
a 20-piece nugget with sweet sour sauce
and fries
so much better it's true jingo's way
better i just had them
what is the reason why we call him jay
bayless for a reason
his offering don't take [ __ ] now over
chick-fil-a that's [ __ ] ludicrous
no that mcdonald's is my shoes in
comparison to those jordans
yeah chick-fil-a's the jordans
mcdonald's that's a great comparison
come on now
that's a great that's what that is yeah
also i want to
let's dress the elephant in the room the
reason why i have the sombrero on
is because every black young fighter
comes out in sombrero
are prone to do ex extraordinary things
really
floyd floyd's uncle
yeah they all done it look at this they
do it because like you're you're
sure it's like you're slaying the they
say respect i think it's more like
you're slaying the mexican
you slam them slaying like you're taking
the mexican out you're dressing me what
about tyson
remember here oh yeah yeah yeah he did
the whole mariachi band
who was he [ __ ] fighting mexican
though no he wasn't can we talk about
how bad javante this intro was with
little uzi vert
i knew you was gonna say that i knew he
was good he was lip singing
yeah but uh like the music the music was
off and it was
really so awkward it was so awkward
why did you do that there was fans in
the audience yeah i was in san antonio
yeah texas don't [ __ ] around yeah was it
like uh
not packed half capacity the only one
did you see the intro
like watch it yeah
look it could have been anybody what's
the song
who knows we don't know i couldn't even
be singing anything
that's bad and we got we got a copyright
thing whatever because we played a
little tiny bit of losi little uzi vert
before
really trouble are you serious about
that now i do what i want
yeah don't play laughter
i thought he was going to lose off that
terrible performance i was like yeah you
started off horrible
by the way so bad yeah leo came up very
simple what is it like who's that rapper
that the mexican rapper he was yeah a
little boy
dude yeah leo boy loco look leo's intro
leo fought well though i had leo winning
two to three rounds
well he wait wait you will just score a
quarter 48 47
going into it i three two leo and then
he got nine three two six
three two or two three the other way
okay i had him winning rounds yeah he
was winning right
now he was doing work he was playing a
dangerous game you can't you can't stand
who is that rapper you see what i'm
saying he was born
oh let me see chin that looks like
robert kardashian am i trying to
the whole thing is no what does it say
martin
martin castillo castillo see yeah so
everyone had right but nobody know who
that is though you know
well i mean in the land culture oh
really you've heard of them
i said in the latin culture chappelle is
mexican on the inside
yeah you know
looks like a mexican bubba sparks huh
you know brian's in that video miss new
booty oh yeah
he directed it i told you directed huh
tried one up in his story it's not good
enough he's in the video he told you to
direct it
no he didn't direct miss why was he in
that video i believe when i got a
salesman who's the salesman in it
hey he agreed to that this is back in
the day
sadie directed i'll turn the music down
but you can see brian here
oh you know exactly where he's at yeah
he's in the beginning you can't miss him
there he is
where right there look at him
that was a little it must be homies 11
no
no why you just why would brian be
friends with bubba smart
i don't know some people were friends
with he's i don't know
he auditioned he got the the part oh he
auditioned for this
he's like yeah i'll do that there's two
on nine brian was selling 17 tickets on
the road
oh [ __ ] well did this help him
uh i don't know i probably did either
way it's legendary [ __ ] though yeah
i mean i think bubba sparks like sober
now he was on that show uh noisy
my what literally one of my favorite
shows of all time no no no easy
on uh spice you never watched that
i think i watched one with henry rollins
and pharrell uh nope that wouldn't be
noisy but there it is
i don't think so which which what city
would that be are they from the same
town because they do it by
city so they like they go to atlanta rap
they went to
l.a where they had kendrick lamar no and
they're like like incre
uh where it was kendrick from crenshaw
where's he yeah he's from compton
so he's in compton and they're in the
back oh yeah yeah no they do one way
they go to
they go to brazil they do k-pop they go
to korea they go to bts
bts ain't having that they're too big
for them oh they're too big they're way
too big
i listen to a dynamic it was a great oh
wow look at him
a beautiful song yeah so he talked about
on there i was just wilding out
so different yeah like he was on so much
yeah like
college park bubba sparks
he was dope yeah
man man look at he looks different he
looked like a guy from friday night last
night now he looks [ __ ]
together i remember oh here's a new
album a new song
can we go to it um yeah but i don't know
it's called november as well as the
crickets
ep with the how's ya
hey hold on i look at that comment i
love instagram comments you go
hauser is [ __ ] whack bro damn that's
messed up that's not out
this in november we could check on him
he said he's back
he's probably on itunes all right i
doubt he has a new video for it
how is it what was it called again i
think shout out to boba's christmas king
of crap
king of crap yeah i love bubba sparks
the season is in full swing and the
action is still unfolding
so head on over to draftking sportsbook
america's top rated sportsbook app
with so many story lines across both pro
and college sports
this is the time to check out all that
draftking sportsbook has to offer
if you haven't tried the app yet check
it out head on over to the app store
right now
because you don't want to miss uh
sunday's
action draftkings is insuring all new
users
covered up to 100 that's right you bet
they cover
with risk free sunday betting that means
nfl
step your game up this weekend there's
plenty of action ufc
nfl college go to it right now all right
on top those great sign up offers
draftking offers great odds
boosts every sunday help you make it
rain draftkings is safe reliable secure
making it easy for you to deposit and
withdraw your money at your convenience
download the top rated draftking
sportsbook app now use the promo code
fighter when you sign up to get this
can't miss offer draftking sportsbook
is ensuring your sunday bets up to one
hundred dollars that's right
you bet they cover up to 100 dollars
when you use the promo code fighter
during sign up for limited time
only at draftkings sportsbook must be 21
and older new jersey indiana
pennsylvania only
risk-free coverage paid out in sight
credits restrictions supplies
draftkings.com
sportsbook for details gambling problem
call 100 gambler or in
indiana 109 with it don't let this cool
weather fool you man you still need to
stay
hydrated properly hydrated with liquid
iv
all you do get 16 ounces of water a
little water bottle
and you get two to three times the
amount of hydration as plain
water flu season often lines up with our
holiday plants but liquid iv
can help support your immune system
whether you're traveling whatever you're
doing
make sure you're hydrated man liquid
iv's best saline hydration multiplier
now has three new flavors guava
watermelon my personal favorite an apple
pie
one serving of liquid iv provides the
same hydration
as two to three water bottles alone so
what are you doing
we got vitamins in them it tastes great
they get freaking they got vitamin c
in them they got all this juicy stuff
for
you what makes liquid iv so effective
well
it has ctt cellular transport technology
all right liquid iv is on a mission to
change the world
that's why they donated over 5 million
servings globally all right
local iv is available nationwide at
walmart
or get 25 off when you go to
liquidity.com
use the code fighter at checkout to get
25 off
anything when you use the promo code
fighter at liquidive.com get better
hydration today
at liquidity.com promo code fighter
it's three years old this is three years
ago
yeah years ago and that's not 11 years
ago no no it's not online
what does your music taste because you
like i like everything you're like yeah
you like
everything okay love country holidays
oh
her dad's black yes my uh my girl and
her friends went to how's the uh
halloween party why did you say that
your dad's black i thought i thought i
oh really oh i like her now too
i don't know i don't know why i said
that all right carry on yeah how's he
had a
halloween party that my girl went to and
her friends and she said
recently yeah it's this saturday i mean
this past saturday and how was it
they said it was great but it was like
it was everyone in the corner they
didn't want to get like the corona
or something they might have a party
well i mean i don't know like why why do
we go to the mall and have six
and go six feet you know six feet yeah
but we have to do that because i mean oh
my
dear lord i know the guy who who dated
her
i talked to him his name is james you
know his name is talk to him
his name g-eazy oh she dated g-eazy oh
yeah they were together forever her she
has that
what is that that's how he came out with
a song about her recently too
but like missing her uh yeah right yeah
was that avatar i don't know no that's
the corpse bride
tim burton oh i don't know that
yeah she's such a baddie she looked good
now i know
yeah did your girl say she had a good
time yeah she said it was nice i was
going to go but the fight was on
but yeah huh
and brendan at the same time went well
yeah she shaved her head gorgeous this
is recent her voice is beautiful
oh man i love her raspy voice yeah look
who like
faces ugh heaven
who's that remember my date oh hot carl
she's got a girl oh girl what a girl a
guy now
oh what is what is love chappelle
love is tight okay i love that why is
her boyfriend look like a grown-up
stewie
let me see how they look at a boyfriend
he looked like that he looked like that
guy who's uh who's in sandlot you play
gold ball like a girl
patrick yeah yeah you knew the actor's
name i feel you yeah
yeah much love what's up she's beautiful
this is your she went on a date with her
in a white no no another one
hey man
i love how everybody just shut them down
he said hey man
just straight boyfriend she was only in
2020 would i get a boyfriend good for
her we'll have to update this on king in
the street yeah
congratulations man yeah congratulations
crackle out there did you guys do it
would you do halloween nights do
anything with your girl
no um i went to a bonfire in huntington
just uh they just put the fire out in
the beach
everyone like gathered they had like
little uh
things little pits fire pits there and
what'd you guys do
we just sat there at the bonfire anyone
get a guitar out no
i'm damn it that's what you do at
bonfires dude yeah
no i wish you jumped on that ledge my
friends
yeah i love that song doug
what'd you guys do just chill out there
yeah we just chilled out there yeah
that's james addiction right yeah james
addiction i went out there with my uh my
best friend
shouts out to tommy tommy do i know
tommy yeah i meant tommy
i haven't met tommy you haven't no way
he lives on riverside
i used to live with uh him and his
husband that means they're gay
oh man that's cool did his husband come
yeah he was there too you were the wait
you thought i'd post pictures of a
bonfire i thought you would have been
cool even your instagram stories
uh did i i don't know you were the third
wheel
there's wheels sorry
oh you can't you can't suck i hate that
of course i know sorry uh
ready no no no i guess not
well that's here look at the studio
kicks
but you were the third wheel with your
best friend and his man
uh were they all in their room no and
they're
no they don't do all that you're like i
mean they do that but not like do they
do it no but they're not like
hey guys that's not that that's what
what is but is your friend uh top or
bottom
you know what i'm saying like he's all
hey chappelle
was he cheerleading with you yeah uh
he's he's r he's
badass yeah like he's really really good
was he the sp was he
i'm not even trying to be funny was he
like the spinner on the team there's no
spinner
like he was like doing backflips and
[ __ ]
i mean he has it all over his damn
profile does he have his instagram
yeah what is it what's his name uh
he's gonna be mad if we bring him up no
so would he would he be considered a
twink
what bro no do you know the gay terms
like is he a cub is he a big
bottom he's a boss he's a bottom
uh yeah he's got videos on there it's uh
tomtom8187
now is he a power bottom you don't know
dog
he's your best friend i don't know what
that means that's his chair number is
that no that
that's him right there hey who's he with
who's the sweater surfer in the front
i don't know what that means i don't
either that's his uh
he he works for her yeah worst picture
uh scroll no dude you're looking at the
worst pic no is this the bonfire you
guys at
no this is that looks like a dog that
looks like hold on scroll
um oh there he is the tumbling's right
down there no no down
here yeah i don't know what he does
there but he's really really good
i love how the guy just like bagged up
before him
he's pretty good yeah yours looks better
though huh yours look better
no he's working he's a little more
explosive his technique is a lot better
he was
uh ex-gymnast interesting yeah but
scroll down he's got one that's right i
don't know where he would label him
he's not really a twink no he's not look
at his shirt he looks like a regular guy
just a dude that likes dudes oh there's
really no it keeps growing
this one that's like really really good
look at us right there
i was at their laugh factory or
something like that
yeah that's my best friend man we've
been how long you guys been friends
uh [ __ ] since since we were 15.
did he that one did you know he was gay
at 15
no he had a girlfriend look at him
yeah that's really really good see what
you mean now
yeah sure his technique is a lot better
than mine but i'm more
explosive yeah yeah that's what i'm
saying yeah
um so at 15 he had a girlfriend and then
one yeah
did you get some hints like in high
school like no i never thought he was
yeah i never i never thought he was he
uh he came out
what like i think it was like 2010 i
just got i just moved back home from
kentucky and uh he was like yeah i
haven't seen this dude for like a year
i said bro why don't you tell me he's
like i don't know how to tell you what
did he say i wouldn't care
yeah i was like yeah he i mean he knew i
wouldn't care i mean like the
cheerleading world i mean there's a
lot of gays you know and it's like a
majority yeah
yeah hey i'd say probably yeah yeah you
know 80
you're being generous say about 70
percent okay
keep going keep going it's about 98 sir
98 oh yeah i didn't get off this road
this is steph curry free throw line yeah
look at you guys i know you're
jacked yeah i was jacked dude that's
what i'm trying to get back to
did you start diet today yeah i've been
doing good you say you lost two pounds
thank you you started today or yesterday
started it today i started today
i know because it was like sunday like
what like not like
i can't diet you know what i had last
night what you have chick-fil-a
nope thai food with my girl uh under 30.
you got pineapple
it wasn't 32 it was it was more than
like yeah so he was right yeah yeah we
all know
we all agreed we i know my food yeah
yeah we got the
fried wontons you know what i'm talking
about the sweet side oh my
come on my mouth is water come on oh
that's like my favorite me too my fave i
would drink sweet and sour sauce did
your girl
did you would where are you guys
watching these shows or no do you and
your girlfriend
last night we watched a social dilemma
have you seen that oh yes oh never how
bad phones are for you
oh my god you're gonna chill out a tad
you think i mean yeah
yeah i oh one there's nobody can watch
that and still be like a dude yeah
there's no way have you guys seen it
yeah i watched it but i was on my phone
wasn't he that guy on uh joe rogan
recently yeah he was yeah it was
it was fascinating this the little bit i
heard it was fascinating oh he was on
rogan i think so
he was yeah okay yeah he was on i don't
know that oh dude yeah it's insane just
like
like everyone like the biggest thing
that i called out of is everyone's like
false uh or not false yeah false reality
yeah you know and how everyone's reality
is so
different across the board like we don't
like as a society we don't have like a
shared sense of reality no like it's
like oh this is
it's in the way that i mean the thing
that that was crazy was like
it was like you could type in um
yeah it's global warming so depending on
where you live
it'll be like it's a hoax it's not weird
and if you live somewhere else it'll be
like
no it's disastrous it's gonna you know
destroy the world
i was like damn that's why it's like so
weird like
that's how you take it seriously no and
that's that's and that's the point it's
like
everyone puts so much emphasis on the
social media like it's not oh it's not
real man it's not real i think that's a
false reaction i think we're going to
find out a lot about social media and
the media
during the election tomorrow night oh
whatever did you look anywhere the
narrative is biden's winning
easily i got a report on it i'm like me
too
i read the news every morning and every
morning it's biting you're getting the
10 percent
timbers there's like he's up by 10 but
then there's a talented man but you you
you go out we try to go l.a or new york
it's like i don't see anything about it
me and my favorite
i've never i never had never and then if
you look at biden's like
when he does like his when he's on the
campaign trail there's like 100 people
show up trumps is like 8 thousand
i'm like there's i don't know man i knew
again it's a coin flip i don't know i'm
not saying trump's gonna win i don't
know
but i think people are gonna be really
surprised i knew i knew biden was
struggling when i saw a clip of
barack obama making a three in michigan
good at basketball yeah you know he had
a court built at the white house in the
white house i tried oh he's like oh so
he gets down
yeah look at this [ __ ] look at [ __ ]
right here
ooh left-handed come on
bro that's this is this right here go
out there
all right we can go up here we didn't go
up you got you yeah you got it maybe the
house and we need to have a court
oh yeah maybe yeah we'll find a car but
you got to play him i'm telling you okay
because i got to set shot
you know also that was last time you
played though basketball's one of those
things
like you gotta stay on it man i haven't
played like at least i've been shooting
with a four-year-old so i don't know how
competitive i still am but
nah you might you way better than
we we played last time we played with
seven months ago on the outside double
rim and you know that's like
you gotta have skill for double realm oh
it's different exactly and then guys
play rough i was like you know i'm gonna
be a comedian now
oh yeah they do foul and they play like
i like to play two rounds oh yeah i
watched you play at 24. yeah
i said watch you didn't want to play
hell no he played one game and he played
one game
no i played i played one game when it
was like four of us and then all these
dudes rolled up in there
they're like yo let's run the full court
oh yeah
you could tell it's gonna be serious
because he had a great voice and let's
run the full
i lost a lot of money oh my god your
bets are
[ __ ] terrible well hold on let's
let's just hear me out would you bet on
okay i've better not football i for one
shoot running by me okay well
next time i will but hold on i was
taking this don't i look like the older
guy in ocean's 11 who is the organizer
of it
if you bring that guy up chin i look my
glasses all right what's this what's
that actor's name
people say you look like chin now i know
i got that so much
really oh
wait what kind of glasses are those um
it's all gucci i don't look at him like
that if you don't ask that question
right he said which one is it this guy
call runner yeah
uh yeah uh no no no no no no
but type in oceans if you type in
ocean's eleven old man he pops
images there oh look at it yeah
they're just a good one yep that's what
i look like i know i'm morphing into
that guy that kind of kind of
yeah i could see that
i got the lenses when i hit the sun
they're going to turn the sunglasses now
really don't hurt them
oh no stop it don't like start changing
yeah don't hurt me
no i don't wait for those different gas
frames too i kind of want to get some
something like that you're going to let
me try them on sure
you want to try it might hurt your eyes
my eyes are hurting already you know how
you get used to them you got to get used
to them they really
i was driving my son home from the gym
last night and they really helped that
night
oh you look dope you look like david
ruffin
ruff david ruffin no you're like you
look like a little rel
lil real yeah i look like david ruffin
from the temptations yeah wow
when he slid out he was like man i'm
dating tell us about your
terrible [ __ ] pics okay well hold on
timer listen to me now now
it was a parlay bet now parley is like
you you you're
more than three are you familiar with
three more right ain't nobody coming see
you otis
hey look uh so so i took i took
i took the ravens over the steelers the
ravens were at home steelers best team
in the league i think okay but
but the ravens was five and two at the
time well what four and two right
uh ravens are four and two yeah four two
okay at the time why not they're at home
hard
dealer six and oh great defense i think
the best coach in the league oh yeah and
then also roethlisberger back
balling from a year off and then he
wasn't even doing anything
but he always wins but then schuster
they thought was going to step take over
for antonio brown
then they have this rookie who is a b
shot to scotty mcknight for telling me
ahead of time
go ahead carry on okay so lamar jackson
if he didn't have those turnovers
we would have won and it was up 17 and
seven so i'm feeling good i'm feeling
good at the house you can't
talk like that during betting but wait
it was it was up 17. they lost okay they
lost all right
then i took cam newton over i mean
patriots over the bills
now let me tell you bill's best team in
the afc is okay and this is the rivals
and i know
bill belichick is not about to have
buffalo buffalo now here's to your jobs
uh the patriots haven't lost to the bill
since i think like 2011.
thank you and then josh allen and i knew
cam newton is destined for a good game
ask me what kind of game did he have
what kind of game
he didn't have a good one chappelle
thanks for asking thank you for a
terrible game
terrible game and he had we had the ball
in his head one could have won
so i lost that awesome but also kind of
a bad pick carry on okay then
are you taking the spread too now i
didn't take the spreadsheet okay
okay i need a hit i'm learning so the
last one and this is what my
me and my dad almost fought over um i
took the cowboys at home over uh
the eagles now let's go over why that's
a [ __ ] stupid bet
why because carson wentz is ballin under
the radar people aren't paying attention
to it
the cowboys dak uh prescott the
leg fell off another one then uh dalton
came in
said hey let me try this got knocked out
so he's out so he got a third string
quarterback
from i think a division two school
starting for them
and no one knows no one knows the guy's
name nothing
so dallas decided to do all these like
trick plays and just got
blown the [ __ ] out no and there's
defense the worst defense in the league
they don't even play they're so bad
they're so bad
so in order for dallas to win the only
reason hey granted they had a terrible
record when
dax was playing but dax went up crazy
numbers yeah but they were still losing
games and they were averaging like 35
points a game but losing
yeah i know but if that was i mean by
the way dak is at home
writing his counter offer right now
because there's no way jerry jones
unless they get
trevor lawrence from clemson but i they
want the jets to get him yeah well
yeah that's true what a nightmare i know
you're trevor lawrence i know i just
said
you're you've traveled lawrence he's the
number one pick from clemson okay and
he's
the guy with the long hair that looks
like a chick guys he's like
he's for sure so let's go number one and
the jets gonna get him because the worst
team in the league
but it's to me it's tough have you seen
the girl look side down
from uh yeah sunshine
um but isn't it weird if you're that kid
like you know you're going to losing
situation
he's like the jets aren't going to be
good for never dude oh it'll take
like being dressed by the redskins like
they're just losers
they're just losers oh damn it's like
burrow getting drafted by the bengals
they're just
losing but he can change that family is
that his girlfriend
but it starts from the top to the bottom
like the organization's
[ __ ] up i know so they're just not
winners from the top but but but making
bad decisions but the bengals made the
playoffs they have
dude years ago and they were stacked
yeah but they had they had a bad coach
yeah don't they look identical oh [ __ ]
it's just a random girl it looks like
them right
yeah she posted it being like she like
yeah she made it she posted it yeah like
oh don't i look identical to trevor
lawrence
wow that's funny don't they look like
this the smile is the same
she's the jay leno chin but that's
different
he's a baller yeah how about how about
the we get off football after this
because
people don't like football they don't i
don't even know
uh finally got i'm thinking of the ufc
fighter
uh uh tua for the dolphins yes sir miami
great start but he beat uh the race get
a terrible game oh he did wait he won he
went 12 for 22 for 90 yards 12 for 23 98
lowest the lowest amount of yards ever
can we talk about how great the rams
defense is like dolphins defense
no i'm talking about he played he played
oh ram defense is solid yeah that's what
we had to play against
so he played the rams that was his first
nfl start and he got a win
i liked tour and i loved it he got a win
he was just kind of there
he he scored a touchdown they've won if
fitzpatrick was the quarterback
no they wouldn't and fitzpatrick would
have though this would have thrown here
to throw interceptions multiple
no okay they're in first place what are
you talking about
the the dolphins are first place he was
playing back
and win the conference was finch was
fitzpatrick playing horrible yes or no
before he took a guy
okay okay all right all right two or
three for 90 yards that was his first
start
who's been winning bets and who's been
losing bets all right then i wanted i
wanted to go i wanted i want to get this
there we go
for nfl purposes and we will get off of
it i am going to console you i'm gonna
reach out like just run it by me okay
copy that
copy that there it goes see yeah exactly
look at that okay
hand in hand come on i don't want to do
that right now i know you did it with
ari menace
yeah john can we talk about your buddy's
diet yeah chappelle sends me this diet i
know diet no no first of all real quick
i know diets
i've done you name a diet homeboy's done
it your friend with the gorgeous
hair and the body that won't quit i'll
give you that his body will not quit
and i love his body
i'll take the diet you sent me let's
just go over this so i'm trying to lose
weight
it was 2 700 calories a day
300 grams of carbs i what's his name
mark mark silver fox mark listen
you know you got a great body you got a
body for days oh you're talking to him
i'm talking into the camera oh speaking
true you know god damn well i won't lose
weight at my weight
eating 300 grams of carbs a day
there's no way listen unless i'm working
out like he was saying
that was an example that he said we
could modify it yeah modify well then
i'll just do my own [ __ ]
no he he has he said he can consult with
us and be like okay
just to get it understood he didn't say
that yeah he did say that i didn't give
you the full like it was a full-on email
yeah he said it was he was happy i
bought it i saw now it's enough
oh okay this guy saw him i love him you
didn't read the whole thing i saw that
was like oh i saw it
i won't lose weight on this he won't
lose weight why would he give us that
then yeah if he knows we're losing
weight why would he give us that why
would he give you that huh i would love
to know
[ __ ] we would love to you know call him
up call him up bro
10 of them call you back you call him
now yeah
oh [ __ ] put him on the phone oh [ __ ] we
put him on online yeah
okay i don't care let's see he okay sure
it's all facetiming [ __ ]
wait wait no wait wait that might be off
wait shirt might be my shirt dog
let me get shred like kim you will never
see me in t-shirts oh yeah everybody
i've been in jeans and never never never
never he gonna answer yeah he's gonna
answer he's connecting so
uh there's that you're you're live right
now can we turn turn it turn it so the
camera
i wish everybody could see you okay put
the speaker on it
but hey we're we're just going over the
diet because me and chappelle started
today
i'm starting as well you're not on the
day going over it
we're just going over it i just told
chipotle some concerns because there's
almost 300 grams of carbs on there i'm a
little stressed out about it
um it was 277 to be exact
why did you say 300. that's closer to
300 isn't it you like to round up it's a
guess let's hear him have had success
with both
low carb and i would consider at your
size that more moderate carb
yeah moderate and depending on
how much you want to work out i it's
really like a feeling thing it's like
do you feel like you need more carbs to
fuel the high intensity exercise if more
you can keep it at that if you like
being full more which i think is the big
benefit of keto that you feel full from
yeah um
then we can ramp it down and i can give
you an example of one that i've used
that's like
you know the only carbs i eat are like
vegetables and
some blueberries yeah look at that see
putting you on games i love good
blueberries
but i just i i did keto initially like
when i first started getting leunited
keto
and now that i'm incorporating more like
circuit style high
high intensity stuff where i'm doing
kind of efficient like
full body in like 30 minutes i like a
little more carbs because i just feel
like
but you're you're burning them right
you're using the carbs because you're
burning them for fuel
because you're burning those carbs off
right because you're doing the high
circuit training yeah
like you're you're using it to optimize
your performance and i still think like
you know because a lot of people when
they're gaining like you see a
bodybuilder or whatever
they're eating for 500 grams of carbs a
day i would still consider
like you know i have to look at what i
wrote down again maybe i missed
uh did the math wrong but um
i would say for you guys i'd really like
you around
if you want to incorporate carbs like
200 you know
and then it's just about adjustment
because it's like if the weight's coming
off
yeah then you can keep it there you know
what i mean yeah it's just that it's a
feel outcome parts are the easiest thing
to overdo so once you start eating rice
like it's easy back oh let me get a
little more rice hell yeah let me get a
little
more of this and that and then all of a
sudden you're 500
you know calories over your deficit
you're in a surplus
and you're not losing weight so that's
another benefit of keto is like if you
just don't eat any carbs you're not
thinking about carbs and you're not
craving carbs yeah it's almost easier
for me if i go like keto
like if i'm real strict and i just don't
touch the carbs usually the best way for
me
yeah so i can i'll write you one tonight
then that
you know would be the same amount of
calories and i'll give you some options
i like to do keto when i do it i'll have
like just two big meals a day and i
could eat steak
yeah fried eggs that's where i'm at
brother
bacon yeah perfect all right man we'll
wrap after this
appreciate man yeah yeah thanks brother
help you guys out
yeah hell yeah this is me chappelle
lacey but yeah we'll uh
i'll put i'll put us in the group text
so like yeah perfect time well we'll
have the uh
idea all right all right thanks mark
thank you so much everybody
look at that leave them up
that's mark what's poppin his nickname
is what's poppin the veins is poppin
he reminds me of ben stiller from
dodgeball yeah
oh really yeah usually that vibe is like
jack that's hilarious
he's so jazzed so jack this is
distracting i know right
you can't even like talk to me it's like
put your shirt on dawg but yeah you're
right if you look if i looked like that
oh i'd never wear a shirt never you
couldn't i'd
my shirt would be off of all the time
would it be like cool
you know yeah i'd be sick oh yeah that's
him i'll do that for tickets
well they call that globo gym mm-hmm or
something like that yeah
well you're right movie's hilarious so
go with the [ __ ] i also like to break
a mental sweat
with a book yeah sure are you reading
the dictionary
yeah ben stitter who is he trying to
impress what's her name
oh wait ben still was actually married
to her yeah that's his wife still
is it oh it's still his wife oh okay
shouts out to them he's a legend dog
have you ever seen the movie
heavyweights heavyweights come on now we
have you have you ever seen heavyweights
oh it's awesome oh yeah that's a good
class you got to check that one
okay i'll check it out maybe we'll watch
it in phoenix yeah yeah
whatever the hell we want so what so how
many months is going to take for y'all
to look like more
with the diet three years wait wait no
that's first of all i like how he points
at me and says three years
you better include yourself in this [ __ ]
bro i don't know bro if i get some help
from some
supplements we'll see what's popping
down oh so you're gonna get supplements
i mean it's whatever it takes to get
shred city baby oh you're talking mom
when you say is that you say steroids
yeah oh okay i didn't i want to follow
you i'm trying to get them canelo toxic
man you know
do those what canelo tacos what's that i
heard that's good steroids
oh canelo take steroids well no he
tested
he popped hot and was like i ate these
tacos in mexico yeah i'm like yeah yeah
me too
yeah yeah what they can't have steroids
in them there's tacos they put in the
beef
but they did they did uh look it up and
there was like steroids in the beef so
it's a little cloudy yeah see come on i
know
give people a chance you're not lying i
i don't know what's good
it's just that you got to be so
disciplined you can't expect results
like
in four weeks i know like you gotta be
so i i don't
personally and again i was a
professional athlete for a while yeah
you really like it's a bad idea to weigh
yourself even after
five weeks because as long as you feel
good you just gotta stick with it's just
about that's right
with it dude yeah and it's [ __ ] tough
especially on the road
because we're gonna be hungry and stand
up lives like oh we got the best chicken
tenders in the city and then
what they do they always get chocolate
they tell me that when they're like oh
we get
and we got a honey sriracha
it seems like we would have to like
let's stick to if we as long as we have
each other doug
all right i mean like you you're already
stressed
you're not like you you're instagram you
have pictures with your shirt off no but
i'm trying to get you look at our
instagram
we have no pictures i have one when i
was keto and i was pretty sure
oh yeah how long ago was this probably
three years ago they called me the keto
kid
it's weird people that don't keep up
like what
they still call you or when i post
something not cute like oh what happened
to keto i'm like [ __ ] that was four
years ago let's see oh let's see
there i am oh you like tyson fury whoa
oh [ __ ] brendan that was three years ago
uh
pr to say when i was posted whoa
was that you in montana whoa look at my
man dawg i see some ass you ain't got
that v no more
no i ain't got that here you're talking
about that dick root though there oh
it's still there it's still there
2016. 2016 four years ago you could just
tell you was killing my uh that's what i
met you four years ago
in 2016. well that's how i looked hold
on go to that one
hits on me huh which one that that's
that was that was straight kita when his
own
straight up that was strict keto damn to
me if you want to lose weight fast keto
is the way
i don't think keto longevity can do it
how much you weigh inside
it's probably 242 there 243.
oh he wasn't sure a city
oh you're like yeah there is right there
yeah you so you was shredded before you
can get back to it i wouldn't say that
do you think that's shredding i mean you
can get back to that for sure you just
don't have any abs
i but i'm not i've never been an ab guy
your shoulders look like mine that
let's take it easy your shoulders don't
look like that hold on i got boulders
i don't think so okay whatever you know
dude but yeah that's that's
all you all you missing is the pack but
you like cut you see you can you can see
dude my job was to work out that's the
difference like now
like like uh yesterday or saturday like
i'll ride my bike for 30 mile
like 27 miles but it's just like that
cardio and that it's like dude that was
my
it's just different it was my job yeah
what if you just start riding your bike
30 miles and every mile you just do
25 push-ups is that a thought you could
do that yeah you could do that
as well oh my jump broken okay i've like
added the kettlebell into the workout
okay each round just do twenty-five yeah
you just gotta get your heart rate up
but
literally but even take all that out of
it it's just about
diet diets ninety percent of losing
weight gosh
that's a high percentage at least that's
the thing yeah but at least
you've been through some people who
don't i know i throw some [ __ ]
numbers
on something 98
are
with your glasses it's more believable
now i know now i gotta believe it
i know yeah yeah
even if you don't work out if your
diet's right you're gonna lose weight
yeah like crazy dog
yeah so but that's the whole that's the
this that's where the discipline lies
because i think anyone can get up and
work out but just like
look at that cheeseburger all the diets
yeah so and we saw that
i've always struggled with it yes we saw
even when i had a goal like even when
like when i was like oh i want to get in
shape for my special like i knew i was
gonna shoot my special eight months out
okay i was going to get in shape and
then it's just like but you're a comic
it's like why why you getting crazy
shaped for that like you're
i'm already i'm i'm not fat so it's like
i don't look
fat it's like why get in crazy shape to
do stand up i'm not fat right
not for the side not
i'll be dead honest with you you me and
jay are [ __ ] thick man okay you and
jay are thick
i like he doesn't want to include
himself all the time
you and jay are thicker than me yeah
look at this hold on this is how you
know what i'm talking about
that's how you know you're getting fat
you sit down i'm tall and you want to
buckle that little put that little genie
right there you unbuckle it like that
and you'll zip it down oh that's
freedom that's i've never had that
problem you're not fat yet yeah
yeah have you done that i can see my
ding-a-ling when i pee
well yeah that's too much that's that's
super fat if you can't see your dick you
just
you got a small dick in b
what you say with the glasses is more
yeah look at him
the stands for everything is this but
you and i are going to stick to it man
we have to my promise yeah who's going
to hold us accountable
i got you and i got all each other
accountability yeah we can do that malik
wants to be a part of it
so bad so bad i don't know how we're
going to incorporate you because you're
not yeah
you just have great like you're thin
well what if you're an ectomorph
well we're endomorphs what wait were you
boxing at 147.
now now yeah but you're cutting how tall
are you i'm six too
that's a huge one is it huge
but you uh you were cutting weight right
i was cutting weight though what do you
weigh right now
a 160. how much you and how tall are you
six two you're so
thin dude you're an ectomorph well
you're
so skinny i'm
i feel like you got a fast metabolism i
do i gained weight fast like in those
pictures i was 185
in those pictures with my shirt off oh
when i was working out and i was on tour
yeah why'd you lose weight the gym's
called
wait quick huh yeah you lose weight
quick it's like it's like spongebob that
must be nice that's a great picture
my girl said you always like jason
darullo she said oh my gosh she said
that she's not the first person to say
that
you keep your [ __ ] paws off my
mother-in-law
oh my god how about how bad it is
everybody is oh dude my mother wants it
why everybody why did they go then she
came out of nowhere
to goddard i almost took my hat off oh
nice to meet him
i just put a little soft kiss right here
on a little earlobe oh
my god oh my god yeah right there look
oh good dude my mother-in-law's a stone
cold
she's a beautiful she's 61 yes
and like bodied up man like people think
my girl's ass is fake i'm like look at
her mom
her mom's ass is reading i didn't want
to oh yeah i didn't want to look at your
queen in that light
i was like i kept telling myself
yeah she got a picture of my mom so the
audience can see i'm trying to get my
mom on there
she does there's my girl pushing us on
that ass
same trainer as theo why does she go
right
in the background yeah that's her oh
that's her grandmother
oh i'm sorry yeah but she's a 10 10
yeah her body's
redonkulous did you see her cat
i've seen her on two separate occasions
she is great looking in photos but in
person she is
different it's different she is stunning
it was just me and her yeah what are you
thinking these stars are crazy
and oh and she'd have a swimsuit so she
just came out of her underwear and uh
brawl i was like god the mom mama yeah
there she is and you know you know that
age is right up his alley yep i know
oh yeah might be a little young for you
actually nah man
the only thing that stopped me is your
father-in-law is a cop yeah
his father-in-law he addressed me as
soon as he was like how are you doing
i'm alex you know i was like yeah i'm in
the workforce i was like
what does that mean is lauren i was like
brother i
i know police that's her singing yeah
she can she used to be a singer she
could sing too
and they're they're from where in mexico
guadalajara
yeah super mexican yeah
can you rewind that a little bit i want
to show the audience this this space
right here
that side of the house right just stop
that do you know
never used he never used that side of
his
his uh uh of of his place that's the
size of my goddamn apartment not mine
most people not my not not my queens
mine now now
he doesn't use he has a tv he has a
couch he has another couch
he has a case he has pictures that he we
don't even care
about he has like you know different
wall dry coat i'm like bro brennan no
one comes in i was like well do you need
one
yeah we just spent all the time in the
other room
oh really yeah like we don't need that
size of a house maybe we have another
baby like
as they get older like it would be more
spread out but
what's so is that my girl in the bathing
suit that one a bathing suit
you'll see if you get out of here out of
here
by the way how about that mariachi keep
going down that was for our birthday
he's like is that my girl in the bathing
suit okay
yeah i'm just look at the genetics dog
that's all i'm saying
look at the genetics it was just i know
right
i feel awkward i don't know i don't
wanna yeah
oh
no no embrace your queen but i don't
want to break chappelle's starting to
get a little bit on chin's level with
his girl
never seen her never talks about her
i saw her when she when we went to
exactly you saw her when
when we had to drive to your house oh
because you went over there
yeah no no she came she dropped she came
to my car she dropped me off she dropped
them off i haven't seen her in like
months and she
still looks the same she's happy and um
come on i'm happy for them shane never
bring around any
functions yeah why that's your girl
you goons what i don't it's a nice time
man she could have jumped in the jump
castle and [ __ ]
i tried jumping no jumping i tried i
took my shoes off i tried to get it
you tried getting the drum kit yeah but
i wanted to too and the guy was setting
up was like 130 pounds math yeah i saw
that
this is immediately right off the bat
i was like yo you paid for this i know
i'm twenty yeah i paid for this homie
yeah by the way yeah all right let's go
some current events you would have been
all right in that jump castle
i think so yeah i think you i honestly
think you would have been at least go
down the slide
and they had a woman in there and not
and no disrespect to her but i knew she
wasn't 135
well she was she bigger yeah she was
bigger yeah i was like hold on she was
watching the child and she was getting i
was like she jumped we can jump
all right yeah no let's jump in surprise
you you could have gotten there cat
uh technically by the weight constraints
i can't i'm 135.
yeah if you're on the you're fine at
135.
i'm pretty sure they're just lying they
don't want adults in there
yeah they're probably that's probably
they just probably 135
yeah i don't know i am a sturdy [ __ ]
muscles power lifting has made me very
like death that's dense
i am dense jim what do you weigh about
200
oh that's nice i fluctuate
sick i don't even know what i am i think
six two but everyone says i'm six years
old yeah i thought you're like six three
but um i'm i fluctuate 196 to 200 around
there
dang you fluctuate that way yeah man
assault man
never been to him uh that's my goal so
that's my father we've all
did you get the sophomore in high school
yeah
weren't you really small in high school
i was one i graduated high school at
185.
oh wow this height six two six
one eighty five then once you get really
big sophomore in college blew up
yeah oh wow so you were playing football
like at that size
yeah oh [ __ ] oh yeah how do you get how
did you get that gross person i was just
a late bloomer
oh blew up sophomore in college and i
was like goddamn what did you eat
just as a late bloomer and then doing
the the workouts the college workouts
you just blew up
i stopped growing in junior high though
how do you stop how tall are you
5 11. people think i'm bigger than what
i am and then they see me they're like
oh you're not that tall
so kim kardashian recently turned 40
years old
and kanye got her um a special gift
where he had somebody record a you see
all the green did i see this
as her father i watched the hologram and
they wrote the script out for him where
kanye wrote a genius kanye wrote the
script
and he's like he's going through
everything you're like oh this is sweet
and then she and then he's like
and oh you're gonna yeah play this it's
like two minutes only kanye would do
make it about him happy birthday
kimberly
look at you you're 40 and all grown up
how crazy is this you look beautiful
just like when you were a little girl
i watch over you and your sisters and
brother and the kids
every day sometimes i drop hints that
i'm around
like when you hear someone make a big
peepee is that a fart
i think it's a fart you make a big piffy
so kanye wrote that drive you to school
mercedes every day and we would listen
to this song together
i am so proud of the woman that you've
become
kimberly and all that you've
accomplished all of your hard work and
all the businesses you've
built are incredible but most impressive
is your commitment to become a lawyer
and carry on my legacy
it's a long and a hard road it looks so
real huh it looks so i'm with you every
step of the way deep fakes are getting
so good now
the way that you're connecting with your
roots supporting armenia means so much
to me
you are a proud armenian and i am a
proud armenian father
the most beautiful thing that i have
witnessed is watching you grow your
family
you married the most most most most
most genius man in the whole world oh my
god i knew what i mean you missed it
about him that was kind of funny
you but he said dead serious he's way
serious the holograms that are dead
seriously amazing
i guess they did you can't stop it and
yeah just gotta say this
now now who was her dad robert
kardashian
he was a lawyer yeah he was part of that
he wasn't just any lawyer
he was o.j simpson's lawyer oh that's
one of them but you know what's weird is
he was
not a practicing lawyer when he jumped
on oj's team
he was retired for years he was in the
music industry
and then because he was so close to oj
he decided to help oj
out because they were best friends dang
that's that crazy then they said oj is
khloe kardashian dead
that's just [ __ ] i mean people
talking [ __ ] but oj did say he had sex
with uh
uh chris jennings yeah he said uh he had
sex with her
in a hot tub and apparently like he like
ripped her vagina or something she
to go to the hospital she woke him up in
the middle of the night
saying that he need she needs him to
take her to the er because she didn't
want to wake up her then husband rob
yeah and he was like no i'm not going to
take you so
she made rob take her to the er and
apparently nothing was the same after
that
oj said this that's what oj said chris
hello twitter world why would you look i
i believe okay
why would he lie he's like you believe
him and that's why he is
you know i don't think that i believe
him for that but y'all don't believe it
when he didn't say he did it
he didn't it's just too obvious he
didn't do it he did it it just
everything stacks up that he did it
like all the evidence i mean that's have
you looked in the case
no i hit my black bell in the case he
said he got a black belt in the case i'm
obsessed would you want a hologram of
someone that you lost um like that no
because i know it's fake and then
someone else is right my brain goes
elsewhere i'm like yeah
who's wrong yeah yeah yeah yeah and like
it's not organic it's not really too
weird yeah yeah like the only one i do
is my uncle pax but like
whoever wrote it it would just i just
like how this is awful yeah yeah it's
all fair
it's not real yeah i couldn't do that if
a hologram my brother popped up
what should i do i'd be like what the
[ __ ] it'd be awkward
it'd be so awkward i'm like what the
[ __ ]
and you know somebody wrote the whole
yeah
trying to like inside jokes yeah i'm
like that yeah like when like
let's say you didn't call it pfe's like
like when you rip a big fart
i'm around or when anybody rips a big
fart i'm around
who the [ __ ] yeah why do they make it
about farts that's weird right
yeah there's no way in hell dude when
somebody rips the big p
fee i'm around now don't even ruin that
tupac and easy hologram that [ __ ] was
tight well they rapping
and we don't yeah that was like actually
pretty cool like i think that's no
you'd go to a concert and pay for that
no if it's part of the show like
it wasn't like a major part of the show
i mean there was a talk about having
concerts where it is the
hologram tupac's classics and he's on
stage as a holiday yeah i probably
wouldn't do that
you could just play his music and like a
venue and i'd be like hell yeah
hold on travis scott had like a uh a
hologram when it was a lockdown and it
was on that uh
well that was a hug that was just the
the video game the video game it was the
game called it's oh tonight yeah that
was kind of dope
yeah but can you imagine a full-blown
concert with a hologram yeah i couldn't
do that
too but i like the way they did it for
tupac where was just like would you
came out and did like two songs peep
this would you go to a nirvana concert
if it's all the band the real band
but kurt cobain's the lead singer and
he's the hologram but the real guys are
in the band
that's kind of cool actually that's
gonna be hard actually i saw them do a
reunion a nirvana where they did it
without kurt obviously that guess
singers but like the surviving members
of the band they did like a
reunion what's that what was that back
2018 like dave grohl he wasn't in the uh
in the documentary you know that the big
hbo documentary have you seen that
uh i forget the name of it oh the kirk
it was yeah cause that was just strictly
about kurt cobain
yeah he but he refused one of the only
members who refused to be in it
oh yes we're gonna yeah because he
doesn't think he commits suicide he
thinks he was murdered
i mean i mean
i'd say brown belt three stripes brown
but yeah i think kirk okay
i think he was murdered oh yeah i mean
this is an interesting
subject like kurt when you ask uh when
you look at it yes dave girl he's like
nah he was never suicidal a lot a lot of
his friends do say like he was never
suicidal was osborne
from uh the melvin oh i know you talking
about the white boy
they're all white yeah what the the
white boy with the dark hair
uh no buzz oliver
but also you know the you know dave you
know the band and uh
kurt weren't talking for a while when he
committed suicide
there was a rift between them wait what
oh
i don't think it was like that heavy
they just weren't talking though yeah
not like
yeah i don't think it was like a super
falling out i think no he was just they
they just needed they wanted to take it
because because they were like just they
just blew up so quick so
you know what i mean like when when
never mind dropped it was just like
an explosion even kurt cobain's daughter
thinks uh
he was murdered oh you hang out with her
no that's what she said in an interview
oh she did yep
oh she said it like literally in the
interview i just enjoy the music
it's a lot to put in my brain i just
like to think about all like that really
it's dope yeah the bruce lee one's a
little shady too bruce
when you look in the bruce lee stuff
damn yeah bruce lee
that you stole from his gravesite
yeah bruce lee's where the like he died
from aspirin he's allergic to aspirin
like i guess i buy that
and then his son he's at his side pieces
house yeah that's weird
wait wait so i didn't know bruce lee had
a conspiracy to
his death no they think the triad did it
right
what yeah remember watch out the triads
y'all tripping are y'all y'all
asian crips out there his son was killed
accidentally i know in the crow
i've seen the crows great film yeah he
got shot with a gun
but yeah it was a real bullets instead
of blanks he got shot and died
that's how he died and they said i know
that but like they think someone did
like did that on purpose yeah on purpose
really
which also i kind of believe if you ever
been on set like what the how they deal
with guns or
being tough to put real bullets in again
yeah you have to go through so many
different people
yeah and there's people on set
specifically for
i think they call it professional gun
department people
ak-47 and like they were all over me
blanks right like as soon as i get done
they grab it
like they don't [ __ ] around oh really oh
god did they grab you
no they didn't grab me they grabbed the
gun like this like this
on you and it grabbed me i mean maybe it
was a little more loosey-goosey back
then
in the early 90s but i don't know but
yeah oh really yeah deliberately they
they didn't know anything about the
bruce lee thing i thought he died from
yeah like
i'll send you some literature on it i
thought he had an aneurism no it's like
a reaction to medication that he didn't
wake up either or something wasn't
feeling good so he went to this house
and they gave him an aspirin they said
he was allergic to asthma
like come on man but they don't think
that's it what's what's what's 12 plus
12 what what
yeah why why would people want to kill
him
there's a lot that goes into it i don't
know who makes these articles
it's i don't know what's from
history.com they leave us some certain
stuff so
yeah i know i don't trust you what else
you got jen
okay so uh megan fox put her
estranged ex-husband on blast because
ever since she started dating machine
gun kelly she's been
very uh public about their relationship
and there was a photo that she posted
with
him and then the caption was something
along the lines of
my beautiful boy you're like achingly
beautiful some
something like that and a couple hours
later her ex-husband posted a photo of
all of their sons
saying the exact same thing kind of
being shady and
ever since then it's been very apparent
that he would try yeah he's jealous he's
kind of like
throwing shade her way and machine gun
kelly's way
he posted this photo originally with the
caption of like
uh happy halloween with his son and
megan fox wrote this paragraph out
basically saying like why did you have
to post this photo
with our son making it seem like i'm an
absent mom like i'm spending all this
time with my boyfriend
i had him the other day that's her own
yeah
hers yeah oh okay i can't post a picture
of halloween with his kids or being like
i think he's making me look like
absentee mothers like
i think it's all the stuff that he's
done before this that's why it's like
one of those things because he's
like subliminally kind of like taking
shots at her making it seem like she's
spending all this time
with mgk and not with their kids while
he's like staying at home
why don't they just call each other i
want to do this
on social media i see homeboy all the
time in calabasas where i eat at he's
there
all the time and uh he was there when i
was there i was getting coughing his
with a
baddie a straight back it was i like
that i like to hear stuff like that
i mean yeah i think they should just
call each other man all right
i like machine gun music i'm a fan of
machine gun kelly
but he's a little bit of a [ __ ] up like
if i'm if i'm brian austin green and
like i got kids
and then there's a video was it two
weeks ago him drunk kicking out a window
in a car
what are you doing this is the this is
the route you're going
like you know how this ends that guy is
a [ __ ]
he needs therapy so [ __ ] bad that
dude
so bad yeah yeah howard turned i was
like man you probably should see it
there but he's like nah i don't need
that man
and howard turns like i'm telling you
you do that however
freaky when people say nah i don't need
that i'm like because howard
howard stone was like dude i've like i
swear by therapy now like i need it so
bad
yeah he's like i used to just lash out
at people and it's like that's what
machine gun kelly's doing
but if i have kids you don't want
machine gun kelly as the step dad
around your kids yeah the name kicking
out [ __ ] windows of cars and [ __ ]
machine gun i mean but he's got a kid of
his own yeah but you know he's like
i don't mean he's a good dad how do you
know
that it is let me tell you something
dude with the glasses it's kind of yeah
he's so high and his daughter's on the
album there's like an interlude part you
know she's good
uh she knows they're talking about
conversation
and she's like dad do you remember like
when i was a kid or anything we did
because you were so
high or drunk all the time do you
remember any of that and she leaking out
and he's like yeah i remember some of it
and just like
[ __ ] dude oh really his name's machine
gun kelly
that's his rap name come on doc have you
ever shot a machine gun
who knows we should shoot we shot that
automatic gun
in texas that wasn't fully automatic
automatic yeah but i'm saying i'm making
an uzi
that's beside the point but what were
you gonna say i mean
all right i mean i don't know the guy i
don't either i'm just not gonna
judge him i'm not either on it yeah
if he had to bet on it i know this yeah
i mean look a little look a little uzi
his name is a little uzi vert and he's
not like
i mean he's soft that dude is so dark
damn bro
so gun so gun so good names he's like yo
it's like
insecurity you trying to well first of
all machine gun kelly that's not
original right
machine no no kelly used to be a gang a
mafia guy in chicago
so that's not original okay so he
already played jurassic continue
i'm just saying i don't think he's gonna
win father yeah
that's not you what about pistol pete
maverick who was that
pistol p maverick the nba player old
school nba
school yeah yeah he's a great uh jazz
show
yeah lsu oh went to pasadena oh duncan
pasadena no dining party he went to he
went to lsu with the college
mm-hmm he played
that's shooting basketball bro what
about 40 glock but but he goes by
machine gun kelly because he can rap
fast that's why he goes by that he can
rap right
now but now it's less rapping more pop
like more
more punk yeah i like i like machine gun
kelly i've heard
awful stories about them offset awful
stories but i still [ __ ] with them
because travis barker is my boy and
travis yeah
travis is literally one of the best
people on earth and he [ __ ] them so i
gotta imagine
machine gun kelly is a good person
thanks for that follow travis
he's great yeah not real let me know if
you want to jam
okay copy that with the best drummer
alive right now you want jam
well wouldn't i that would be honest why
not was last time you jammed
uh like a full-on band yeah ah that's
been a minute probably
uh 2000 remember when i did it on stage
um yeah just give me how many years ago
i think it was like two years ago yeah
that's a long time he plays every day
man kiss my ass doesn't mean i don't
know how to jam with a band you can play
music you play music play music
you can go you can go go into a gym
right now and get some ufc
[ __ ] going down no you can get a pop and
you can
the basics of just rolling around i
wouldn't be i wouldn't be like hey jon
jones that's [ __ ] when i'm in town
let's spar
you wouldn't you wouldn't no god no i
know my [ __ ]
your weight class not your weight class
though yeah he's my weight he's like hey
no john's a heavyweight what you think
heavyweight he's my heavyweight but
you're a thick heavyweight yeah that's
true
is that a division yeah it got to be no
i got i got to be there's going to be
five
heavyweight no i can make 265. i'm like
261 right now
john's probably 240 right now i didn't
expect you to roll around with someone
20
that's heavyweights though doug oh yeah
206 265.
oh wow the point that's such a big gap
that's a big the point is
he's the best drummer on earth and i get
that now you haven't played in quite
some time
and you're trying to jam i've been
playing in quite some time
i got you damn with a van i play my but
that's different if you're playing your
guitar constantly
yeah you're fine i don't know i don't
you know what i don't know bands exactly
i know i tried to use the ufc
yeah that was bad i thought you were
gonna go to the comedian route i was
about to say put in comments i don't
know where you're trying to go yeah i'm
trying to go
yeah like yeah you hit some yeah
communion of like your favorite comedian
you're like hey let's do
a show together yeah yeah but i'm a
practicing comedian i have
six shows this weekend i constantly do
stand up
now if i took four years off i'm like
hey bill burr first can i jump on your
show he'd like
no problem you know what i'm saying chan
like if you're playing guitar constantly
yeah and then when you're rolling with
someone that's got drunk
hey when i played with that band i
didn't know those guys you killed
it i just started playing out two years
again two years ago dude well how many
months would you did you play before you
started jamming with those guys two
years ago
which guys the guys that she was yeah
did you build up too much oh no actually
no
a couple months ago is when the last
time i jammed with a band you're making
this up
no i'm not i just can you record
something yeah well yeah
bunch of songs he got an album coming
out oh for cats
no no no for something else it was me my
me and my homies we wanted to do some
punk covers
yeah and we we recorded it in this
studio hey fun fact
are those guys professionals yeah they
play with kill tony
oh the comedy band yeah let's just leave
that right there yeah hey bro
i'm talking about traffic i'm talking
about travis
mother [ __ ] barking i mean they said
suck nah but travis
cry away from travis and i get that i
get that i'm saying like i don't think
it's weird that
okay prince wanted to jam with dave
grohl
and prince can play every instrument
instrument yeah so what does he need to
jam with anyone for he can play every
instrument and really good
dave grohl is a professional musician
you know i know my truth i know what it
is let me see you play more man
i'm sure traffic's like yeah i'll play
with you just play more but he just
shouted them out
so i'm pretty sure they you know we'll
see what happens i would love that
yeah it'd be fun would you do something
if they were if i wish i could play an
instrument
are you gonna play anything no i wish
not even like
what about the school i don't know i
can't play the drums i play what about
the uh what's
that thing in school there's a recorder
it was called a recorder yeah
they dip it and they're dipping in scope
i remember i'd always put my lips on be
all sweet
by the time i was in school you had to
have your own because they didn't want
to do that no they had them at the
school
back in my days there's only 12.
there's only 12 of them and they were
soaked and scoped
mouthwash and i would take them out like
that's disgusting
that's the way they did that [ __ ] on the
tip
i would deep throat that flute dog yeah
that's how you sanitize back in the day
yeah yeah
it was delicious yes yes that is the
part
that had enough money to just everybody
have their own aurora public schools
there was
12 flutes there was about 13 kids so we
all was one person yeah we all shared it
all sharing ain't no way we're about
coronavirus
okay y'all didn't take it home in the
suitcase like a lot of people [ __ ] damn
no that [ __ ] stayed at the school we
took it home if it was taken home it
ain't coming back
no hell no missing break yeah yeah you
left at the school and you dip it in
school dividend dip it in that [ __ ]
oh this one's for you it's all dripping
wet
and you would blow it and the mouthwash
would come out
that it was so unsanitary i think it was
fantastic it could have caught something
it was she was different back in the day
it was much
else better yeah much better wait huh
okay
okay the world's not on fire there's no
riots
what else you got uh so trump is
planning to
declare victory on tuesday if he is
leading in the
votes regardless of how the actual
outcome
is i don't know what's gonna happen
because this is what's crazy to me
so there's 90 million votes pre like
before like early
voting there's 90 million these [ __ ]
idiots because they're still
based off the 1790 days they're not
counting the votes until
all the votes are in why not start
counting the votes now
so we don't have to wait all this
[ __ ] time oh yeah because when
there's this many votes dude
we might not know who's present in for
another three weeks like a clear-cut
winner probably three four weeks yeah
what
yeah what are they just doing like hey
we are we already have these ones each
night
yes how many we have next night this how
many we have yeah and
you don't have to announce to the world
but then the night of count the ones
that come in then
tell us the next morning like we're
gonna go to bed is it tonight no
tomorrow night tomorrow we're going to
bed tomorrow night you're not going to
know who president is
why don't we have voting day as a
national holiday
we'll take off work yeah
i don't know i don't want to talk about
politics
yeah it's weird i don't know what's
gonna i have no [ __ ] clue we were
talking about it we think chin might be
in trouble
he lives in downtown that's why i'm kind
of happy that it takes a little while
for the k
the votes to be counted yeah it's going
to spread the anger out yes it's going
to spread
instead of let's say tuesday night like
trump wins
you say you're trapped i'll be trapped
i've been trapped
yeah you just need to go stay with your
girlfriend yeah i'm gonna figure
something out where's she at
huntington beach oh she does get what's
there
no but wait huntington beach is close to
where they're pro trump right
oh yeah i was there yesterday with
my mom we were going to visit my
grandparents there's just a bunch of
vietnamese people like selling maga hats
there's a bunch of like super oh
vietnamese people are super republican
so you go to orange county there's a
bunch of asian people that look like
they're related to me
selling like trump t-shirts wow they
call him uncle trump
in vietnamese like in the community how
do they say it uh i'm trump
i'm trying to yeah it's like it's kind
of like respect to someone older so it's
like that's our uncle trump
when they say yeah like hopefully
saturday night they're not like trump
wins
and there's [ __ ] riots in arizona or
some [ __ ] phoenix
okay wait wait wait we go to we go to
phoenix we go to phoenix i know that's
why
i said that oh oh i didn't oh wait hold
on time i don't know how old arizona is
so many old people there oh they want a
riot well they don't get down
they looted the mall right that was the
mall bro that was that was also jake
paul in that
area you know you don't think we have
any problems out there dude no
it's an opening carry state though let's
yeah i think so yeah yeah okay well all
right well we'll see so we'll fly back
to chaos
he's freaking freak outs people are
freaking out
yeah stay off the internet i watched
social dilemma last night you little
little shits yeah but but that was so
similar but those people that are
creating the chaos are the ones that are
doing all the protests and [ __ ] yeah
they're still gonna protest
still gonna do it if trump wins dude
it's gonna be chaos for about 70 days
well that's what i'm gonna just keep
throwing up look this man gets new
glasses and you guys think
he's throwing out a lot of stuff i don't
know he's like i can't keep up he's 70
is 80. he's 98.
he might as well be sitting here
there's going to be protesting and
looting going on
i think that'll wear out and that's you
said 70 days
hold on not 70 days of protesting 70
days of the
far left making it hell man hell
season like just like you're giving them
too much credit yeah i hope you're dude
i hope you're right
i like your i like your i feel like
you're going to i hope you're right but
what if bonnie wins you think it's going
to be a protest as well if
nope if body wins we go back to normal
faster
okay i don't that doesn't mean i think
he's going to win or i think he's the
right choice
but if he wins if you want things to get
back to normal faster
probably that maybe but also biden wants
to lock [ __ ] down
so if by the winds we might be locked
down here
luckily i love you guys you know i don't
want to talk politics yeah
what else you got it's all it's all i
can't wait for this election be done
and we just move on hopefully whoever
wins shut the [ __ ] up
that guy won they spoke moving on move
on
move on i think no matter who wins
life's going to move on the economy is
getting back to normal
corona is going to be not such a big
deal we're getting back to normal so
next year we should be straight
oh 100 by january no matter who wins
we're gonna be straight my birthday's
january 23rd shout out
hell yeah let me just choose for your
birthday oh you will yeah if you let me
set those on fire
all right now compromise compromise
maybe talk about some beautiful [ __ ]
pants
vans are dope there's some dope vans and
i like vans kanye wears fans a lot of
cool people who wear vans
i got some vans those aren't dope uh do
you know what
i mean and then the hole in the back no
you've had them for
you've done thousand all these things
look how worn down the [ __ ]
front toes yeah i know i slip whenever
it rains and should i be slipping
you can ride a bike greatly knows though
that's how deep do i you know i um
yeah i know a lot of my shoes i've just
had for like years that's like i've had
some
like there's a pair of vans that i've
had since
oh uh 2013 yeah last time you played
with a band but here's the
[ __ ] now he was jamming out and
those like couple of yeah
shoes look dope weathered those don't
like some some shoes when they're worn
in look way better yeah they're
literally usually air force ones look
dope
dude these would be dope once you use
them i got a pair of um
they're uh 96 air maxes from
sean weatherspoon and they're uh
corduroy and the more you wear them
they like tear and they get different
colors
oh wait whoa oh it changes i don't wear
them enough for them to tear in like
that but they're dope
let me see oh is that it oh those right
you got those
oh you're [ __ ] right i got those from
my boys at suplex
in philadelphia damn you probably got
looted and don't have any more
uh no i'm about to start tying up my
legs though
yeah oh wow those are corduroy so when
they rip
there's like cool stuff underneath them
i didn't know that i'm gonna have to cop
some
okay mm-hmm yeah i'm gonna be probably
my favorite shoes
yeah i like that colorway and i never
wear them i don't know why
start wearing them man i know i need to
okay oh wait
real authentic oh the fakey dates
oh the wave is by the way waves
different the wave of like a dr
seuss wave oh wow i couldn't tell good
thing
no yeah uh yeah if you give me new shoes
for my birthday i guess i'll let you
well that's what i'm getting for you
my birthday is december 23rd yeah oh
[ __ ] your b-day
yeah right before christmas before
christmas what a shitty birthday i know
i don't that's the wild
is your queen gonna take you out well
she wants to but she was like yo what
what do you do i was like every year i
don't celebrate my birthday i hate
breakfast yeah yeah it's gotta be
i hate birthdays i know yeah oh nothing
worse but uh they're cool when you have
kids like you make their birthdays off
yeah yeah my parents never did that but
um for you
are you asking your queen for anything
nah i literally i literally had to
listen her birthday was last week we
celebrated
oh would you get her wrote i got her
something last night so she was having a
horrible time her friends came out from
since uh ohio and she like paid for
everyone's bill
like she paid for the for her birthday
yeah for her birthday bro huh her
friends were broke
no no that was like then mommy cr like
oh she paid for justin too yeah we told
the story yeah justin
you told troy on what uh that's your
house that's your house
oh i missed it oh bro let me tell you so
last time i probably missed it because
my halloween suit caught on fire
it was before that oh word tell me what
happened yo so last week it was her
birthday
and all she wanted how old did she turn
first of all she turned 30.
i thought i'm dating a little older you
know i like him a little older you know
yeah
so she turns 30 and all her friends fly
out so we're going to be 30
30 30. so it's the one time you turn 30.
you know you make it special so i tried
to
i like yo justin come invite he was like
alright cool where were we going we went
to this fancy restaurant
in santa monica what was it called ma it
started marin
it started i don't know mexican moroccan
no oh sorry i'm mexican
like monday i don't know but either way
we get there all right okay
nice spot they had a mariachi band
playing through the glass that's how
nice it is
now i know i want to i want the real
thing okay now i didn't know how much
drinks cost
i was like all right cool we just gonna
put it on one bill the bill was 700
something dollars how many people was it
it was like at least like let me see
justin yes
yeah there's nine people nine people
yeah dude that makes sense okay nine
people i don't drink you know alcohol
alcohol appetizers appetizers everything
here and the dessert the cake was there
a big [ __ ] there
you know justin was there so okay all
right so look
uh every bit of 900 keep going
so the bill comes yeah so my girl she
already like puts the card out
right i was like yo look little black
thing and uh i was like well what are
you doing she was like listen up don't
worry about it
let's just pay for it now like i'm over
it i'm like yo everyone's like we're
gonna build more
out ain't request you tomorrow of [ __ ]
this was justin that was like no we're
gonna do it now this one justin said no
the lady said let's be more hurt
that's the most justin move ever
she had to pay for her b-day meal now we
go to another spot
right for drinks for drinks this is how
dirty justin is
so we're at drinks right we're all
everyone is at the table
and we're drinking in santa monica now
we go to uh knotty pit on sunset so we
drive all the way back from santa monica
to sunset
all right well if she didn't want to end
over by there yeah we live over there
about there so
that's my queen anyway so we we at the
table right the bill comes again now
this guy
i homie pays for it but this girl leaves
early she leaves ten dollars on the
table
nobody sees this knowing damn well sh
her drink was taken
exactly so look justin
had a honey in his pocket the whole time
he kept trying to pull it out
but he kept putting it back in right he
was like y'all don't need me okay good
you kept putting it back in oh yeah
this is how dirty it is so once he saw
that uh homie paid for the drinks and
the tip
that ten dollars he took it in his he
took that two dollars
put it in his pocket now the guy sees
him the whole time he sees him the whole
time
he thinks i think my homie is having a
conversation jesse just sit there he's
like yo
he looks at me he's like i'm about to
get out of here i was like
he left with the ten dollars so he he
had the most dreams he didn't pay
anything nothing
yes matter of fact he made money he came
up with ten dollars
so last night i just threw her a
surprise birthday it was me jessie and
her closest
justin again and justin in favor i don't
know how we keep inviting justin
you were a surprise birthday party where
uh at uh this place called
spartina on melrose oh cool hey did you
get an invite no
i didn't either very [ __ ] strange i
lost a lot of money yesterday and i i
knew if y'all came
y'all wasn't gonna pay so i had to come
out of my mind
that is your goddamn right i should have
invited you i'd have been a free member
but but it
is but it's her birthday it was her
birthday and i wanted to like i also
don't know her so
yeah exactly so i was like yo but she
would listen to the show she loves you
holla yes martinez yeah you see how
beautiful and nice
and here's the thing they let us book a
8 30 spot they closed that nine
what kind of [ __ ] they kicked you
out nah she was so dope she let us stay
to 12.
really yeah oh that was a great time we
was having so much
i'm sorry i'm so what did you get your
girl for her birthday
besides throwing a free birthday party
what do you do with a queen who's making
over
you know certain figures like you gotta
you gotta you gotta get creative you
gotta
pottery you got to make a painting well
i gave her a painting
i got i said oh yeah indoor she already
i already gave her to indoor pick that's
right i already gave her flowers in a
cart like what do you get a girl who
like literally can buy herself whatever
she wants
you know what that's another man the
best thing you can give her
the best thing you can give her that big
date well yeah you know i put it down
you know i gave it you know i gave it
out yeah thank you bro hell yeah
let me just tell you something oh would
you pop some john jones uh gas station
know i ain't pop a pill bro i've worked
i work i'll work fine you know and plus
i get up when i know she her break
account is that big
come on come on man that's all that
motivation i need yeah you didn't get or
anything that's cool
what yeah he got her long story short
you got her nothing yeah nobody just
said long story short she paid 900
for her birthday well yeah but she needs
new friends
yeah he's hoes that is true flew from
cincinnati
columbus she probably paid for it and
here's the thing we went to uh eplp
on sunday and they took all those
pictures and stuff like that and the
bill came
and she still alligator arms alligator
yup yup
the fake yo yeah i'm not gonna lie
i'm not gonna lie i hate the fake reach
i hate the
like oh do you want me to get it on and
i'm like damn what the hell yeah
or or what after someone puts a card
down like oh i didn't i
why didn't you say something i would
have paid like yeah well you can still
pay
yeah i was like now you got it you got
it yeah i'm like she's
disaster were they were they decent
looking yeah they were they were
like she has some bad friends but
they're not as established as her so
sure
yeah so of course they look good and
then they bought her boy the one girl
bought her boyfriend
they had a free ride because they stayed
in our spot [ __ ] when i say our
hearts place
and i was like yo they we really tried
to give them the bed she was like no
just give them the couch and they had
she bought them a hotel she paid for a
hotel
at uh yeah that's depressing what was
that what's that spot over there in
hollywood
that uh roosevelt the roosevelt she was
over hollywood boulevard yeah
yeah yeah and she just threw up so i was
like you know what you do a lot you
spend a lot of money on your birthday
let me just get you something let me
throw you another birthday party you're
gonna pay for
no i'll pay for it i pay for it yeah but
you paid me with her card
yeah i didn't know i used my card i
wanted to use her card but i mean
because hers is black mine is rainbow
right bro what else you got uh let's see
this one uh yeah so apparently paris
is gonna be going through a second
shutdown people heard about it and are
frantically trying to get the [ __ ] out
of the city
watch what happens they try locking la
down again that's not paris
that's paris that's pierce compton
that sucks wow that's happening people
revolt man especially with the the
scientific
facts they have now and [ __ ] about who
made this video
who made it abc news everyone where
where where are they going though
anywhere but paris because paris is so
locked in like a long england's lock
down right now
everywhere germany is starting to lock
down london too
that's crazy that sucks that makes me
mad now look at us now
are we going to be locked down see now
you're mad see now you get to see that's
what this that's right you care about
politics yeah you're right but it's just
it's just so much
oh dude i love this this is my favorite
thing ever
oh my god the back flip and twist and
[ __ ]
it's called a round off full look how
gangster he is
oh get it
get in my g with pads on pads
on that's skill that's crazy big skill
to do that with pads on yeah
look at that i don't know homie but he's
like i'm a fan he's probably
cheerleading um
is he a really good player hi pretty
good colts are solid this year oh
they got phillip rivers they're five and
two what's his position running back
running back he's short too as well kind
of got a little school
yeah that was gangster yeah yeah should
have hit him with a hit stick
um i didn't read this but brennan i
didn't understand this so i was figuring
maybe you guys knew
so he deactivated his instagram captain
what was wrong with his batman outfit i
thought he just
he was brown batman he was chocolate
batman yeah look at this oh i will say
nerds get really upset when you change
anything about their favorite characters
yeah but those nerds
why would he deactivate his account
because that many nerds were upset that
he's brown back maybe
probably recon first of all yeah don't
read comments this guy put y'all bully
trav scott's costume so much he
deactivated his instagram account
it happened with uh zendaya when she
first got casted on to
spiderman because her character was uh
supposed to be mj
but they had to change her name to uh
like michelle
something the initials are still mj so
she's like
the new version she's not mary jane but
she is
mj she got so much hate for it because
she's black wow and so they're like
she was black yeah they're like mj's not
all black you can't have zendaya
i'm just a comic book yeah that's the
thing we were like what are they serious
about that kind of what's mj yeah
mj is mary jane that's uh spiderman's
love redhead do you love me man
oh she was married jane for halloween no
uh she's casted
as mary jane in the movies now please
tell me you saw spiderman homecoming
no who's your spiderman vera you've
never seen spider-man
you don't care about superhero movies
either no music i like spider-man i
don't [ __ ] with marvel any of that
gay [ __ ] blasphemy spider-man
yeah you don't like the avengers hate it
you don't like hulk i hate it speak on
it what the
nah nah i can't yeah it's hard for me to
get in that [ __ ] you got
i feel like you have to have like a
special imagination for them
i'd say yeah no not low iq
iron man was the smartest guy in the
universe iron man i didn't mind
i just don't like the avengers the thor
like the make-believe world yeah but you
know what i used to geek out over is
like the old school like shaolin movies
the kung fu
that's why i started doing flips because
i would watch those films yeah
fantastic dude
no here's the other problem you got a
nike sock with a van shoe
with a hole in the knife with a hole in
it dude it's the nike socks and it's so
funny i keep i keep washing them
and keeping them like i like it like i
shouldn't get rid of them because they
have a hole in them
it stands out because you know if you
know that
you know i don't even know what to say
chin do you like uh like avengers and
[ __ ] like that nah i'm with you i don't
when i saw thor i thought it was just
like a like a cartoon
yeah that's what i'm saying it's hard
for me to get into that you watch wonder
woman
no you didn't watch blackjack watching
did you watch my
panther like miss marvel where the [ __ ]
it was no no you're talking about uh
miss uh miss uh miss marvel miss okay
that's what i said um
venom was decent some are cool so like i
like venom my son likes venom
you like the darker ones like the toby
mcgregor is my spider-man
i love the i love batman you look like
that that's not even marvel that's
decent it's still comic book [ __ ]
yeah but it's like i can't get into
thanos and then [ __ ]
the rings oh yeah i can't get into that
so that's that's where like i get
i like like documentaries i like like
gangster [ __ ]
i do too i watch it's different genres
but you gotta appreciate the art of what
they're doing no i was saying i
appreciate the art i just it's none of
it's original they're all it's all ideas
from a comic book that's always
already been written do you like
boardwalk empire
yes okay that has nothing to do with
we're talking about well
i mean yeah i guess it's a real time
period like that's real like i can [ __ ]
with that
that comic book stuff it was a real book
that all they did was take the book and
put it in film
that's real to some people i don't know
do you guys remember that movie split
that supposed to yeah related to some
sort of comic book stuff and they tried
to
put it all together i like that he said
it's in the same universe yeah
mr glass blessed and unbreakable yeah i
like those but splits more i mean
grantee turns that weird like yeah
when he all those different i i think
she's been nominated for a [ __ ]
oscars
but he's playing all those different
characters he was so good yeah
but that's just like someone with mental
disorders like he was a superhero that's
just a crazy
that guy needs better help better
betterhelp.com promo code
boy boy what about the guy that's on
hollywood boulevard dressed as batman
does he needs mental health issues
no he got a fight with one of those
dudes on hollywood oh wow whatever
uh he well he beat up uh what's that
movie wolverine
uh transformers no the um with zach
galifianakis
and they lose their friend the hangover
yeah he got a phone with a
you got a fight with a dude that looked
like that well he ain't quite a
superhero yeah but what
was he just says do you remember the guy
was dressed as zach alfinecus and uh oh
yeah little baby thing weird and he
charged that uh
mark weird he like ran ran up at him
like charged him and mark just
clocked him out yeah what what punch uh
i think he hit him
oh that doesn't matter he ran into a jab
i just wanted you know okay i don't know
what else you got
this right here i didn't read this
either this is yours nuts yes venomous
snake hiding in a pile of toys
bites a toddler in tennessee look at her
post though chin
oh there goes my precious 19 month old
emmy joe
was bit by this copperhead which is
poisonous as [ __ ]
copperhead hiding right besides our back
door with her toys
many of you have asked how big the snake
was this is it when asked at the
hospital
logan killed it with her husband he said
he didn't even know the first thing he
saw
adrenaline was kicking we were both
hoping it was a chicken snake which
isn't venomous
but when logan went back and moved the
toys his heart immediately dropped
into his stomach please please check
your kids toys let me see
where i'm at it's rattlesnake territory
so like when we go like play basketball
body killer yeah smash it with something
that's so dangerous for kids though
they're little bodies yeah oh yeah so
dangerous
and venom too uh is the baby okay yeah i
think she's okay
if she's at the hospital yeah i just saw
her foot looked pretty swollen
by time i said like he's like oh my
fashion has snaked out i'm like no
dude he thinks he's the best thing in
the world but there's rattlesnakes all
over
like where i live you know so my thing i
said do you see a rattlesnake you
[ __ ] run the other way and come get
me
most of the time those [ __ ]
aren't trying to mess with anybody well
that's well it's like that snake was in
the toys
so oh he's gonna bite you yeah it seemed
like when i see rattlesnakes on the
trail it's like you don't need to be
scared of them
but if you run over one on accident or
you're hiking they're going to bite you
oh 100 like some hiker just died like
two months ago
hiking uh somewhere died yeah straight
up died from a rattlesnake
and you didn't make it down or i don't
think so on time you you only have like
i think an hour
before you serious trouble sheesh and
you're not supposed to it's like sucking
the venom out of fake
you're supposed to uh put ice it
whatever you're supposed to ice it
really you're not supposed to be
somebody that's fake
isolation a tourniquet even but the
you're just supposed to put ice on if
you have ice
cream so why did they tell us like suck
the venom out like yeah they didn't look
like an old
dog come on brendan knows he's got these
glasses on he just told you he did this
i believe he said i believe come on keep
throwing numbers out
icing okay listen don't suck a snake
bite okay
don't suck i would say evidence suggests
that kenan's cutting and sucking or
playing target or ice or ice does
nothing
um although outdated measure still
accepted
um keeps with a say so it doesn't say
what to do huh
see research i believe any by prostate
will lead to illness or death that's no
longer the case
about 25 of all pit viper bites are dry
don't contain any of the snakes
dangerous venom
in addition since the advent of
effective anti-venom
the death rate from pit viper bites has
dropped to less than one half of one
percent
oh kind of like corona uh back in the
frontier days
all right so basically just get to a
hospital because they have anti-venom
okay so that's all you can do is
antibiotic
anti-venom okay so get to the hospital
immediately but what if i'm hiking like
a boy
and he get i'm taking my chest sure
enough you're in trouble yeah i'll take
my chair i'll suck it out if i'm up
there on the height
because he does nothing you're not
sucking it's already in the blood he's
already in a blister
but to their point though those snakes
it's not they're not doing it to kill
you
yeah they're do and you they're doing it
just to get you away so they're
injecting with venom most of the time
according to this [ __ ] i don't know
webmd that was written in like 2002 it
said
yeah yep august august by the way
well sorry much louder than her
hopefully they're doing well now little
bunny
yeah i hate when children like you hope
you guys are doing well dog
last night i was showing my son i got
tiger out of the shower
yeah and he's telling me some terrible
story right he's telling me
he's telling me the story and it's like
he's been talking about all day
and i look down i see this fat ass
[ __ ] spider
fat spider in his room usually i don't
kill spiders i'll pick them up put them
outside i don't kill them
because they'll kill like mosquitoes and
stuff which i hate way worse than
spiders
this one was so fat in his room but i if
i if i've been like damn dudely that
spider would have freaked out not slept
so he's just talking i was like oh
that's cool buddy really what else i'm
like
i get a tissue this [ __ ] spider was
so fat it was like i was crushing a blue
belt
it was so big it was like so
graphic it was so bad but that i mean
you gave a great explanation yeah oh
dude
like the blueberry because you could
just imagine i could feel
i could feel them like pushing the
kleenex like this like not today
and then i just like popped it oh dude
just
why did you let him go guts everywhere
he's in my son's room so i yeah i mean
this it yeah yeah you can't have it yeah
and where did he keep your composure the
whole time yeah yeah way to keep it
fashionable i think it was he goes papa
what's that man like what i opened up
because is that a boogie
i was like that's a boogie yeah it's big
dude
that's aggressive great by matt by the
way was it harry
yeah hearing like big fat butt
i can't stand spiders like the [ __ ]
mickey nicki minaj spiders i just pop
that out
everything everything thick in your
house i see [ __ ] up everything thick
boston the thickest one in that [ __ ]
one more sure all right vin diesel has
another signal that came out yeah
he has a what another single he is
putting out he's crazy
no one could tell them [ __ ] i'm about to
walk at this in phoenix let me hear it
all right so that was on time
that's in new york yeah so fun is that
real or did he focus
that's real i want to share a prank that
someone sent me from my hometown new
york
so basically uh 16 year my father took
me and see whoever's done he's just very
happy that since he can't do movies
right i'm not hating on him man
play it obviously we can't pick is it by
is it by
uh another big guy i think it's the same
producers i don't know
days are going it's completely different
didn't i go do the first one yeah a
little more lyrics this time
monday tuesday wednesday so you can
learn that guitar look at this oh yeah
i want to bad just if you just not
if you picture someone else not vin
diesel sometimes his music's not
that bad yeah because it's a unique
voice it made me want a bachata
you can't hate on the guy he's doing
what the [ __ ] you want here's the chorus
killing it
i'm for reals i'm not mad at his music
at all
that's not the dance dude that's that
was trying to give them
i was with your boss mariachi but
chocolate oh man it's not bad at all i
respect it me too
that's horrible maybe man that's hard
that's hard i like that you think it's
better than feel like i do though
of course springfield i do that
run it back feel like i do when did we
become a vin diesel fan club
i don't know i love him he need to he
need to shout out to vin diesel
he wants to come you know sit and talk
with us
that'd be a weird conversation or maybe
he's the best that'd be dope
yeah because he because he would let him
go i'd have him do this live
yeah now this he has more he has better
lyrics than the last one
oh i don't know the new one might be it
thank you this is the the beat is harder
on this one
well that's kind of doing the beat shout
out
oh because i'm about rattlesnakes hit my
boy at the bottom there mike pois
i took a pill in ibiza you guys know
mike at all yeah yeah he's great
you know he's running from uh california
to new york i think
oh he did yeah denver and got bit by a
baby rattlesnake
i didn't know that yeah he write a song
in every city uh jog pass
he's such a talented guy what's that
song you had with uh
you'll know this one for sure uh if i
could write you a song
to make it no was it where's khalifa he
was featuring on the song
he he has like a very unique story he
like
um had this uh what do you call it like
understanding moment
you know where this life-changing moment
where yeah he was like caught up in all
this fame
and then he literally was like yo my
life like things were too wildy
he was like he goes i go to parties and
i wouldn't i wasn't being myself
yeah yeah so he cleared out all he goes
i was buying nice cars and i didn't even
like nice yeah being awesome but yeah
yeah but you like nice cars i do but he
was just doing it to like he thought
that yeah
he thought that's what people like but
then he just like took a step back lil
wayne
really changed his life play this song
for me
well he's saying that what he's talking
about he's good life
you know yeah i'd love to take some
guitar lessons this is so beautiful
you could probably be really good at it
you never know yeah guitar or drums
that'd be fun
i know i play drums do you yeah
seriously i know i never know i played
oh [ __ ] he did that
oh no no you haven't checked out me for
a second oh you should check it out
though
what's it on again why is that wrong no
one season's free because season
10 on netflix oh it doesn't yeah it
doesn't matter what i started
no it doesn't matter yeah all right
start with season 10 that's what got me
all right we'll watch that [ __ ] yeah do
it yeah bro they took project runway off
of hulu
bro why you always doubting me bro the
drama i don't know i don't believe
you've played drugs i don't know you've
played drunk never said
that literally yeah i never told jesus
and he plays music and
you've never brought up drinks i've
never been friends i never you been
friends how long bro you never seen me
cry on spot and i
i showed you like i said i wouldn't
yeah the bonus episode that's fire you
can't do the the drum sets or the actual
just one drum
i can do i play drums so actual set
well no no i could just do the uh okay
yeah the drum so that's the drum line
yeah yeah i can do that okay
i don't believe it okay when i bring it
here all right all right i'm gonna bring
it in here and we're gonna
i'm gonna prove both of you all room and
we're gonna we do want to bet we wanna
just yeah you did that it's like he said
i play drums like you can
yeah you would have done something like
okay but you said i you know
okay i'll put it bro i would never i
don't think any drummer's ever described
yeah i play the drums yeah i can do this
okay yeah i can play the drums because
my hands is always in motion even people
that i just did
is that it that's it well
this [ __ ] drummer will be in phoenix
thursday friday saturday tickets we
might be on shows tickets low
on sale this thursday friday saturday
phoenix stand up live november 5th
through the 7th
me and this crew with a special guest
that is this week
phoenix stand up live in two weeks we
are in nashville
also with a special guest nashville
zanies
that is november 19th through 21st then
boise
that [ __ ] is almost sold out we're
going to add an extra show probably yes
sir boise idaho december 5th
one show only as of now in a theater out
there in boise idaho
get your tickets at tfk.com any thick
boy gear related thick jerseys thick
sweaters
thick girl [ __ ] thick fanny packs thick
hats thick
shorts thick socks we got it thick
boy.com
we got some dope merch i'll show you
guys that's this dope merch drop in
for black friday so get your minds right
dickies think boy.com
but phoenix we will see you this week
chapelle what you got for him yeah
november 27th through 20th tempe 10 p.m
prof thanksgiving weekend
coming home bring me some stuffing yeah
well i mean make sure it's like
can i eat stuffing okay i could pick out
on thanksgiving man you could have a
yeah we should do a cheat meal yeah i'll
be stretching
yeah i'm doing a cheat meal thanksgiving
give me some stuffing
yeah i like a turkey with some gravy
like potato salad cranberry sauce
cranberry sauce
what else is good on thanksgiving bread
pumpkin pie
pie pie peacock nuts in your mouth
actually [ __ ] pecan pie i don't like
that [ __ ]
hello kiss my ass with that miss me with
that uh and then also
merge chapelle ac doc still waiting for
myself
i [ __ ] have it you have it this
weekend your friends bringing it mm-hmm
all right we'll see yeah you'll have it
this weekend maybe i'll wear it on stage
yeah yeah what do you got i mean
i'll mention up the black dudes on this
i did it i was just saying spell what
else you got yeah
go ahead baby we got some updates with
uh
yeah coming soon
well shout out hey shout out mike getty
shout out jacob warvoor and shout out to
hey we're outta here